I want to thank the NHS for so much
including getting me back here and I
might add very much happier hospital
visit yesterday in a few minutes I'm
going to hand over to Patrick and to
update you on the epidemic but first I'm
going to set out today's latest data 900
1905 tests for coronavirus have now been
carried out in the UK including 80 1611
tests yesterday one hundred and seventy
one thousand two hundred and fifty-three
people have tested positive that's an
increase of six thousand and thirty two
cases since yesterday fifteen thousand
and forty three people are currently in
hospital with coronavirus compared to
fifteen thousand three hundred and fifty
nine people yesterday and sadly of those
tested positive for coronavirus across
all settings twenty-six thousand seven
hundred eleven have now died that's an
increase of 674 fatalities since
yesterday across all settings this
figure of course include includes deaths
are not just in hospitals across this
country
therefore families every day are
continuing to lose loved ones before
their time we grieve for them and with
them but as we grieve we are
strengthened in our resolve to defeat
this virus to get this whole country
back to health back on its feet and were
determined urgently and in particular to
overcome those challenges that in the
last few weeks have been so naughty and
so infuriating I'm not going to minimize
the logistical problems we have faced in
getting the right protective gear to the
right people at the right time both in
the NHS and in care homes all the
frustrations that we've experienced in
expanding
the numbers of tests but what I can tell
you is that everyone responsible for
tackling these problems whether in
government or the the NHS or public
health England local authorities we are
throwing everything at it heart and soul
night and day to get it right and we
will get it right and we're making huge
progress and I will not under eight the
work and the achievement of those who
are dealing with global shortages in a
global pandemic they are rising to a
challenge we have never seen in our
lifetimes and the same can be said of
the entire people of this country
staying in enforced confinement not
seeing family not seeing friends or
grandchildren worrying about their jobs
and the future and so my message to
everyone again today is your effort and
your sacrifice is working and has been
proved to work today
the number of kovat hospital missions is
falling the number of patients in ICU is
falling we've so far succeeded in the
first and most important task we set
ourselves as a nation to avoid the
tragedy that engulfed other parts of the
world because at no stage has our NHS
been overwhelmed no patient went without
a ventilator no patient was deprived of
intensive care we have five of the seven
projected Nightingale wards and it's
thanks to that massive collective effort
to shield the NHS that we avoided an
uncontrollable and catastrophic epidemic
where the reasonable worst case scenario
was five hundred thousand deaths and so
I can confirm today that for the first
time we are past the peak of this
disease well past the peak and we are on
the downward slope and we have so many
reasons to be hopeful for the long term
the UK is leading international efforts
to find a vaccine today
Oxford University is announced a
partnership with Astra Zeneca to develop
what they believe could soon be a means
of inoculating ourselves against this
disease but until this day comes and I'm
afraid we cannot say exactly when it may
be we're gonna have to beat this disease
by our growing resolve and ingenuity so
I will be setting out a comprehensive
plan next week to explain how we can get
our economy moving one how we get our
children back to school back into child
care second and third how we can travel
to work and how we can make life in the
workplace safer and in short how we can
continue to suppress the disease and at
the same time restart the economy a huge
amount of work has been going on on that
plan and of course as we produce it we
are being guided by the science and we
will try to build the maximum political
consensus as we produce it across all
parties and across the UK but there will
be five key tests that we must satisfy
before we can put that plan into action
we must be sure that we can continue to
protect the NHS and its ability to cope
number two we must see a sustained fall
in deaths three we must be sure that the
infection rate is falling for we've got
to overcome the operational and
mystical challenges on testing and PPE
if this is the most important we must
all make sure that the measures we take
do not risk a second spike that would
overwhelm the NHS we've come through the
peak or rather we've come under what
could have been a vast peak as though
we've been going through some huge
alpine tunnel and we can now see the
sunlight and the the pasture ahead of us
and so it is vital that we do not now
lose control and run slap into a second
and even bigger mountain and so to avoid
that disaster our fifth and final test
is that nothing as I say we do should
lift the are or the reproduction rate of
that disease back above what